right now there's about 40 000 chemicals
on the market and i think a lot of you
might be surprised to learn that less
than one percent of those
have actually been tested for human
safety and too often
these safety standards are set by
political interest or
science that's been manipulated by
companies that put
profit over public health all of this
is to say that industry pollution
by and large goes unsupervised and the
laws that we do
have unfortunately remain woefully
unenforced
water is not immune which should leave
all of us very concerned
so today to walk us through this
quagmire and
how we can actually be part of needed
change my guest today
is the one and the only erin brockovich
perhaps the most famous name in
environmental activism
best known for going head-to-head with
pg e over polluted water in the town of
hinkley california
in a case that resulted in the largest
settlement ever paid in a direct action
lawsuit
in u.s history it's a story that ended
up on the big screen
it's a story that garnered julia roberts
and oscar
and turned the name aaron brockovich
into not only a household name
but actually a verb aaron's got a new
book out
it's called superman's not coming which
i highly recommend
everybody check out she also has a new
podcast of the same name
and today predictably she brings the
heat
if you enjoy this channel it would mean
a lot to me if you could please click
that subscribe button and hit that
notification bell so you can be
alerted every time we post a new video
thank you i appreciate it and with that
i give you
the mighty the whip smart and the
imposing force of nature
that is aaron brockovich
[Music]
all right we're on erin brockovich is in
the house i am thrilled i'm so excited
thank you for doing this oh my gosh i'm
really glad to be here i don't think i
knew we were such close neighbors
i didn't know that either i would have
had you on forever ago oh my god live
like down the street from me yeah
literally you've been here forever
and and forever i know god i'm getting
dated i also didn't know that
that that massry's office was in
thousand oaks
yes i know corsa avenue so after the
movie came out he came out that way and
bought the building
you know it has since passed on they've
now sold the building so
the whole firm and all of that is gone
but no we're locals i mean ed used to be
mayor i didn't know that yes
there's so much to learn i was talking
he was with claudia de la pena i believe
that she's been mayor i mean so
he started the whole save the open space
and oh my gosh
wow ed was the original yeah he he
passed on
a couple years ago yeah ed died in 2005.
what a loss he was a great guy
yeah i was with him when he died i was
folding his hand and his wife and son
were there and
um you know ed had a huge heart smart
guy
um just always jumped in to help he i'm
missing
yeah every day i can imagine i mean what
a story it's just
it's incredible he was the best friend i
think i've really ever had
yeah i mean the two of you together and
what you were able to
create and set in motion is so epic
i wish he was here today to see
everything i mean you know and ed
ed could always make a joke he was fun
he'd make you laugh he could be
light-hearted but serious
he just was optimistic he wasn't worried
things would always turn out and
i could just share stories with you for
days
the movie seemed pretty crusty
is that accurate absolutely well he had
an extremely dry sense of humor
and you know he he always made fun of
himself
i mean oftentimes you know he'd show up
in his slippers and
and we'd be at a you know community town
hall and he'd say you know
my mom may not have birthed the most
handsome but you know she
he would always make some joke about
himself separating
yeah yeah which is was fun cool so yeah
he was cut you know he could you know
i think he definitely always got a kick
out of me mm-hmm because i cannot
challenge him yeah well i mean he'd
never seen anything like you before
that's for sure he's like what who talks
to me that way
so i was talking to my friend
asher gunsberg who interviewed you in
australia last year i don't know if you
remember i
do and i went and listened to that
absolutely he's the best
he is you know and i love australia yeah
it's the best i spent the whole month of
december there this past year where'd
you go um
in uh in bandai and then byron bay
yep byron based i was ready i was ready
to stay byron on the byron
yeah you do a lot of stuff there you go
there a lot right i'm supposed to be
there right now
i cry because i'm not there i really do
enjoy the country i enjoy the people
i've been all over to this day when i
get my hands on a koala i
sob like a baby it's ridiculous yeah
but the people are wonderful they are
and i do remember that interview
very much he's a pro he's a pro but what
he did at the beginning of the interview
i'm sure you remember
he put water in front of you that was
tap water right and i was like oh my god
and so i brought water out but this is
this is purified water it's all good
it's safe i think it's safe i don't know
you know you be the judge i suppose
well you know it's interesting we even
start up that way i've decided every
single day
you know my book is out superman's not
coming i have a copy for you in the car
oh thank you i've been listening to it
on audio i'm really enjoying oh have you
oh my gosh i you know
i i don't i don't really have like an
ego
and i'll come into a situation and i'm
usually like okay i'm not sure
let me check you know check this out uh
doing my audio for my book
piece of cake yeah uh no
wow there was days after i got done
doing the audio on that book and working
on pronunciations you know it's one
thing when you read it and you say it in
your head
then when you say it out loud they're
like uh you have the no you made a
necessity
you got to get that right do the
pronunciation again i almost thought am
i illiterate what am i talking about i'm
like
my eyes were frying out of my head i
didn't like the sound of my voice
it's exhausting i've done it myself and
you get it all gets up in your head and
then you're like why can't i talk
right i've been saying perfluorooctanoic
acid forever
and he goes but actually you've been
pronouncing it wrong i'm like
what i was like there's no way so
i'm glad you're listening to it yeah i'm
enjoying it i'm enjoying it and i love
the title superman's not coming i mean
it's
it encapsulates kind of your whole thing
which is this idea
that everything's kind of apocalyptic
and no one's coming to help us
and yet also hopeful that in this
destruction we can find a way to be
self-empowered
and those two ideas kind of crashing
into each other
really kind of defines your whole path
and your whole career it has
and you know going back to the water
here that you brought in
which you know it's always that moment
somebody looking at it
skeptically yeah you know unfortunately
i always brought my own little dream
down there but um
water's kind of a metaphor uh because we
are water
and what i've learned in these
communities is once you know water and
understand water
and have that connection with the
environment again you actually find
yourself
and i do think because there's been such
crisis with water
we've actually moved away from this and
we've in a way lost ourselves
and i think we're waking up again and
finding ourselves
and finding our voice and things that do
matter like the water
like the air like the environment like
our health
and i don't know if for a long time we
got comfortable
or we bought the illusion or we took
things for granted
or we just got complacent
but what gives me hope is the fact that
i think we're waking up to a lot of
issues
that have existed for a long time and
it's just spilling over
it's devastating the more that you learn
about how so much is mishandled and
bungled
by these institutions these regulatory
bodies these corporations in which
we invest some level of public trust to
take care of us like
maybe superman's not coming but
shouldn't you know the government
of one of the most powerful uh
prosperous nations on earth make sure
that we have clean drinking water and to
discover that that is very much not the
case
is incredibly disheartening like it's
and it's scary and i think
to read that now in this heightened
moment that we're all experiencing it's
even more
disappointing given that we're seeing
kind of structures failing
all over the place or public distrust
and structures
um starting to kind of increase like
it's not just
water we're looking with that we keep
our eye at
all kinds of institutions at the moment
and
there is a public groundswell of not
just distrust but also
activism that we're seeing so i guess in
that you can glean the
sliver of hope absolutely you know the
distrust has been there for a long time
i'm a foot soldier you know
so to put this i don't know in some
context
well i began my work in hinckley i just
turned 31.
i'm now 60 with four grandchildren and
the idea that when i did hinckley
everyone thought that was a one-off
and i found out it's the entire u.s if
not
global our groundwater issues our
contamination and through that process
i've learned where
the system failed whether it was
designed to fail
whether it just got you know hijacked if
you will
uh there's all kinds of ways to move
information around
uh the politics that get involved i've
been the bearer of bad news to many
communities
but we do share with you in the book and
we show these communities
that when the people know and oftentimes
they don't
for a lot of reasons because there's an
assumption
that an agency a city council
a state a water board a municipality
federal oversight something's got your
back
that it's been missing because they're
always going how did we get here
and in the book we share with you
communities that
take the information knowledge is power
i will tell you 10 times out of 10 is a
pissed off mom
and they do great things they make it
their business
they make it their job they get involved
they inform their neighbors
they become one and then five and then
10 and then 50 and then 100 and then 200
they get into city council right in
their own backyard
and they they affect change whether they
get led out of the water
whether they run for office they win
they get referendums on the ballots
hannibal missouri is a perfect example
they had led as bad as flint
but the moms fixed that problem and they
ran for city council
and they won those and they got let out
of the water it's
it's an amazing story what is it about
your mind is it that like
protective instinct that they have or
their keenly aware sense of when
something's not right
and yeah and their willingness to speak
up about it like absolutely why moms
they're you know i've i've
watched it's amazing like i'll never
forget when
uh my daughter elizabeth who lives here
in thousand oaks and has three kids she
was a little
girl and our dog gabriella had puppies
and oh elizabeth you know got to be
involved but as soon as all the puppies
were born she went back in
gabriella snarled and snapped at her and
she's like what is that and i said
that's mama bear you know these are this
is her turf now
and protection that that that sense
kicks in
i watched the same thing happen with
elizabeth when she had her children
and we we have a very protective nature
especially you know we feel hard we
love hard we nurture hard we're mothers
we're protective and they oftentimes
activate when their child
or a family member or a friend's a
friend's
child is harmed and they worry about
what will happen to their health or they
have cancer or a disease or they make
the association or they find out it was
water or an
air contamination or a medical device
gone bad
they rally and they do it strong and
they follow through
they are they don't let things go so
if they're in it they're gonna be in it
to finish it
so moms are great yeah
when you look at what's going on in
hinckley now like hinckley still
has problems right with the water he's
gone so the town has
disappeared everybody left right but
they still haven't really
cleaned no they're under about a hundred
year cleanup order
god pg e is the worst example of a
company
that i've monitored and been against for
20 years
and they could be doing things
differently and we
see this i think there's a big breakup
break out moment right now
where our policies and our
infrastructures
and our laws are outdated think about
this and we're still
working on that it's not going to take
us forward and pg e has been a perfect
example
from hinckley where i started to the
kettleman case
both of these communities settled
between 333 and 335 million dollars
defense costs you're looking 50 100
million on each
clean up costs on their corporate books
for the next hundred years
hundreds of millions of dollars we're
talking uh two billion dollars right
there
you just follow them up the line and
their infrastructure
is so distraught and under such stress
that they never take profits in
reinvesting in infrastructure
safety and people first they want to do
the money first they want to do it
cheap and they want to be deceptive you
know they blow up
san bruno i mean my gosh let's talk
another 50
million on their books we all saw what
happened to paradise
i was involved there the northern
california fires all because a company
over a 20-year period doesn't want to
reinvest
in its safety infrastructure and people
period had they done that the first time
we wouldn't had hinckley we wouldn't had
kettleman we wouldn't had a san
bernardino we wouldn't have had those
fires
we wouldn't have lost the lives we did
and destroyed the environment had they
just done the right thing
we really need to re-look at some of our
business models because we do things ass
backwards
and that model won't sustain us in the
future right i mean capitalism is set up
for that like the corporation
can't be relied upon to look out for the
public welfare it's
concerned with its quarterly p l and
the stock price and all of that so
they're going to make those kinds of
decisions and that's why we have
regulatory bodies and we have laws so
walk me through
why the epa and our kind of legislative
landscape
has failed to become the adequate safety
net that we need to protect us
well kind of what you just said you know
somebody asked me once you know
who fails more agencies or
companies i don't know i don't think
they sleep in the same bed
and well we got scott pruitt right now
yeah for for a whole host of reasons
they are the money matters more
and the agencies succumb to that
and information is concealed
um you don't always have the right
people getting the right information
and they put it in a box it's forgotten
about
one thing i do see going on is
a lot of suppression a lot of bullying a
lot of labeling a lot of fear
uh you didn't see that unsee it you're
gonna lose your job
gets thrown in a box and there's a good
way to play the shell game
to kind of move the data around listen
you know pg e on those
those fires it took uh i believe was the
wall street journal
dug up documents i mean we have this
amazing freedom of information and most
people don't know how to access it
found a document filed with the state
the pg e
knew 18 000 miles of their transmission
lines
were going to fail uh how'd that get
overlooked
was it deliberate or did somebody throw
it in a box and didn't know what it
meant
and so we need to have the right people
in the right jobs
looking for the right information and
how we stop
the the bullying and and the suppression
out of fear you know listen
whistleblowers come to me all the time
and they they come to me because they're
terrified they're going to lose their
job
if they say anything and they know
something so they're desperate to get
information out
this isn't something that just started
yesterday though i mean it
boggles my mind i began my work 1992
and it's 2020. we're still talking about
it yeah
it's is it any better or is it it's
worse right
it is absolutely worse because we just
keep
kicking the can down the road and
we you've got to have the right
politician that's going to really stand
up or our leadership
to a cause or issue but oftentimes they
rely on someone else
and then the company gets them out and
pg e has a huge role to play here
in the state of california and i think
our government our leadership here
has allowed them to run as a monopoly
and get away with what they have
so we have to find better ways for our
leadership
that don't succumb to the pressure of a
big company
politics campaigns finances
and all that gets convoluted for the
sake of money
and then the issue at hand i don't know
goes away
i mean it seems like we've got to reform
the lobbying
laws to prevent the influx of money that
influences these politicians we've got
to prevent
the kind of shuffleboard game of people
going back and forth between high
ranking government positions and ceo
jobs at these companies because it just
becomes
an old boys network where they're
scratching each other's backs
and the public is lost in the sacrifice
meanwhile
science is bought and paid for it's
manipulated to serve
you know a certain narrative and we
suffer
and without people like you we're
lost and it shouldn't be that way
well there's here's again where i see
the hope it is very daunting but
we the people have always been absent
from from the equation because
trust trust is gone and what i do see in
communities
this happened to me i'm too familiar
with this so i recognize it pretty
quickly
um i have dyslexia so very young in my
life
i was teased and bullied and labeled and
judged and put into a box
my mom always taught me just because
you're different doesn't mean you're
inferior
and quickly in my life
uh you know i was labeled or judged or
perceived even in the film
because of the way i dressed or walked
and this assumption
this girl can't possibly have a brain
and i get into communities in hinckley
and this
is why they don't speak up or speak out
because they think and a lot of us do
that if you're not a scientist
you can't understand science and if
you're not a doctor
you certainly couldn't dare speak about
the illness of your child and possibly
be right
or because you're a mom or because your
socioeconomic
factors are different or because of
racism which
is existed out there in the environment
that there's this idea
you're not the best educated maybe you
don't know you're a mom therefore you
shouldn't say anything
and we hear that and we're like oh you
know what maybe
yeah you're right and we just kind of
pull back
that happened to me my whole life i
recognized it
and i pushed out of the box in the
beginning of that and every community i
go into it is the exact
same thing they have already tried
to reach a politician they've already
tried to write to the company they've
already tried to talk to a neighbor
and it's the same thing i don't know
about that i doubt it's the water that's
a conspiracy theory
our government wouldn't do that to us
you're going to damage our property
values so there's a whole
mechanism that goes on and it's been
going on and on
and on and on and on and on and on and
on and i think
this is where we are today that wake up
call where we've
been deceived we're clearly getting
indication we have
we're really upset um we've gone through
covid we were locked up
i'm not sure that it gave everyone that
moment
to really start looking because we're
always so busy
what the hell's going on and while
it is awful right now
i've learned you have to go through that
clash to slice through the
if i'm allowed to say that on your show
yeah you could say whatever i didn't
drop an f-bomb no
um to see it we can't
fix our problems if we don't see it and
we don't act and respond to it i'm not
in favor
of all the the violence i'm not
tearing down buildings burning is i'm
not
but this is a result of decades of
distrust disrespect not listening to the
people
labeling them and judging them and
putting them over here and hoping you go
away
and casting the situation aside like
we're all a bunch of idiots and i just
think it's boiled to a head
yeah the pressure valve it just just had
to explode like this is a natural
you know progression of what's been
going on for a long time
i could tell you i see it out in the in
the communities
well i know that when you go into these
communities at least initially perhaps
not today but
the response is who are you you're not a
scientist you're not a lawyer what are
you doing
here your opinion holds no sway or
merit go away right and it was only by
um dint of sheer perseverance like
when i think of i mean the book the
title of the book is like superman's not
coming but if you have some like
superhero
qualities it's like this incredible um
perseverance you know like a dog with a
bone you're not gonna let it go
no matter what you have uh incredible
people skills which i want to talk about
i used to be a corporate lawyer so i
know
you know like the blind spots that a lot
of lawyers have when it comes to
actually trying to get things done in a
community
and also something that i think is
tremendously overlooked
you talked about dyslexia and your
learning disability but you also have a
photographic memory
right that's because of my dyslexia is
that you ha did you have to train that
in you or did you always have that like
the movie the moo
you get these great speeches in the
movie where you get a glimpse of this
but it's never
like sort of expressly acknowledged or
addressed
i've always had it you know my mom used
to always say when i was a little girl
and my mom was a journalist and a
sociology major
school teacher well educated my dad
well-educated
a mechanic not a mechanic a mechanical
engineer graduated from ku
he ran the pipelines for citigroup yeah
so water started at the very beginning
at the very beginning for me and mama's
like you cannot beat this girl
at a game of go fish you can't
and you know dyslexia was
really misdiagnosed back then and we
still have issues with it today
but my mom always intrigued me
as a sociology major and a journalist
she knew immediately
something was different but that if my
self-esteem
was lost i'd be doomed she knew she had
a fight to get me through the school
system
and she was the first one that told me
you got to have stick-to-itiveness
which is still my favorite word today
which is actually in the dictionary
it is noun propensity to follow through
in a determined manner dogged
persistence born of obligation and
stubbornness i'm like
wow that's all you had to say to me mom
and i truly became
the little engine that could i think i
can i think i can i know i can i know i
can't
we i don't know where this idea
started that we have to fit in this nice
little neat box
and oftentimes education can be a
standard of conformity
and so i was different and then i needed
to go into special ed
and i didn't fit in and my mom taught me
just because you're different doesn't
mean you're inferior and i utilized that
stitiveness and i kept finding different
ways
to work with something one thing i did
find out is
i was fun and i could make friends and i
liked
people um and that was a way to cover up
for what i felt was
my inadequacies one person that really
helped me
was my high school teacher kathy borseth
she saw the same thing
but instead of pigeonholing me and
saying
and immediately labeling me not knowing
what was wrong but seeing that i was
different
she pulled me aside one day she said you
intrigued me
i said why is that she goes because
i know you know everything in class i
know you hear me
you're the first one with your hand up
but i give you a test
and you failed now i can read well and
good
but how i code is very differently and
that coding is what helped me figure out
hinckley and every
thing else that i'm doing in my
environmental work and she said
what's up i said i don't know dyslexia
something like that
she didn't miss a beach she goes hmm
interesting she said so let me ask you a
question
if i give you this test right now are
you gonna pass it i might
yeah she goes i'm gonna scramble
everything up i'm like
be my guest she did she goes oh my god
you didn't miss one question you got an
a plus she said i'm going to do this for
you every test
every pop quiz every semester every
final
she gave it to me orally what she did
not only for my gpa
but my self-esteem was everything
and there is such in every community i
go to
starting in hinckley there is a mom
there there is that persistent person
but she's
pushed back you're crazy you're not this
you're not that go away
so when i went out to hinckley i'm like
i
have been here before if not my whole
life
and this perfect storm was brewing and i
found some courage because i remember
standing there
looking at a two-headed frog and green
water
and somebody from pg e said oh that's
the standard
i was like i started to own
what i saw and oftentimes we don't own
what we
know because you get that voice in your
head
and then we just go away i see it
everywhere
but when you get in there
i'm like i'm you you're me i mean we've
experienced this
i'm not afraid to be vulnerable i'm not
afraid to tell you i don't know
those people ask me questions and i'd go
if i know let's get the lawyers on
the phone they're like
oh my god i'm so glad you said that
because i didn't want to be the first
one to say i didn't know
and to be real and i'm not
perfect but i code differently
most dyslexics do so what had happened
for me in hinckley
where we had a big breakthrough was a
report
written by environment and ecology
stated
1992 in one paragraph it stated that
1992 the monitoring wells still had 5
ppm hex chrome in them now i had already
learned enough about hex chrome to know
that that was a hazardous waste level
that's a lot of freaking chrome and that
90 of the chromate
had already been removed via
agricultural
and domestic use i immediately went oh
my god
it's 1992. it's still 5 ppm
if 90 has been removed via the people
what was the number in 82 what was it in
i go backwards that's where i code and
calculate
and guess what pg e knew in 1958
that chromium-6 hit the aquifer at 58
ppm that number changes
everything especially on dose response
ratio and exposure
and what would have happened to those
people and that's how i think
that's how i code but forever it was
different
and i was perceived as a special needs
child because of that yeah it all goes
back to that teacher
giving you that kathy borseth for my mom
that's beautiful
so and that that mother you know i do
share this story
um because it's important to what we're
talking about my own daughter
um and my first granddaughter's special
needs and she has a manual syndrome
and elizabeth was told and i was there
most of them was very rare walk talk
thrive to survive
and i saw beth she said hell no
i saw that mother that person that
instinct that loved that compassion that
moment of courage and i've got this and
we can do it
and i'll tell you what today grace is
walking
talking thriving i watched her right out
here in thousand oaks at your special
olympics 100 yard dash and i could cry
she did it and that was from her mom her
mom believing in her
and pushing her even when it was hard
and here she is today she's the apple of
my eye and we we can overcome
but i think we forget so much about
how we can overcome and it isn't just
book smart it's compassion
it's trust it's stick-to-itiveness it's
feeling it's okay to be different it's
okay to be vulnerable it's okay to be
imperfect because none of us are perfect
and somehow when we brace
embrace that and we just have a sigh of
relief
it gives you a space to believe in
yourself
and actually love yourself and um go out
there and give it a
really good try was that the
grandchild that kind of catalyzed you to
come back because you've been doing this
for a long time but you've stepped back
a little bit i guess for a while but now
you're
back in full force was she she was part
of the
absolutely yeah i was there when she was
born
she did because i just like oh no i'm so
reinvigorated again and
and what is the world going to look like
for them i think we all question that
right now
and uh i'm in that fight and again as a
mom
and a grandma and often times that
instincts that intuition i'm i'm in it
for the long haul
and you know oftentimes the other side
whoever they may be you know i spend a
lot of time thinking who are you
and where are you that's out there that
we think is either against us or is
going to fix this but um
i'm in it for the long haul that's
dictativeness as my mom said um
you're not life will require that you
have stick-to-itiveness
um you may not be born with it but it's
developing the habit of persevering even
when you don't want to
and would be easier to give up so when
you're first
working with masri and you're carrying
around this doggedness this
stick-to-itiveness
but your life up to that point had been
a lot of
you know banging your head against the
wall and not really
making your way in the manner in which
maybe you envisioned for yourself
when you get that file and you see that
paperwork about
medical records stuck in this
essentially a real estate deal
do you have a conscious sense of like
there's an opportunity
here for me like what what was your
awareness level like that stuck out but
you were a file clerk it wasn't your job
to go
investigate at that point but there was
something that clicked in you
that said i need to know more like here
i'm going to go on a journey with this
curiosity i was smart enough to read the
medical reports
and because they were done in a bar
graft so it didn't take a rocket
scientist to figure out what the hell
a lot t cells what are those i looked it
up
so white counts what does that mean
looked it up all of this stuff was off
the chart
and mom kicked in and curiosity kicked
in
and i'm like what if that was my child
i'd be worried and that's what kicked me
off
was just my own oh my gosh this is weird
i'm curious why would this be happening
what's wrong with the children what
would i do if i saw blood work like this
on my kid
that's where i went yeah in the movie
that that woman is played by mark
helgenberger right yeah
she but is she a stand-in for a variety
of people
or based on a real person because in the
book roberta my sense yeah my sense was
that she
she knew kind of in the book she was
more up to speed and more suspicious and
knew more like it it plays in the movie
like she's less suspecting of what's
happening
well if you remember in the movie when
julia first meets her it's roberta
walker
and she she knew enough because she was
already asking questions that's why i
was there
and and you see her connect the dots in
the conversation
and she goes my god the water the kid's
the pool
roberta was already there when she looks
out and her kids are sure
in the pool and that's how i got
involved beginning with roberta's
persistence and like i told you in every
community there's a roberta walker
yeah there's an erin brockovich oh
they're there yeah and then when they
joined forces
we started really getting some stuff
done i still
talked to roberta all the time i was
just on text with her the other day
she's amazing
and she's one of those moms and she was
done with the and she had been
pushed through enough
and you know we talk about in the book
when people come to me like even roberta
when she first came to the law firm
in a way they're looking for permission
if you will
to act and what they really need is
support
and when i showed up and i'm like oh
hell yeah no i wouldn't deal with this
if this was my kids i mean it starts
there the support
starts there and this is something that
was really well thought out to keep
covered up
yeah and so the community they didn't
know
who to listen to and then once
we got together it's amazing what
happens because nobody ever wants to be
the first to say it and we don't wake up
every day and ask our neighbor
did little johnny get diagnosed with
colitis and have you been having chronic
nose bleeds and weight loss we don't do
that
and once we started getting roberta come
to the firm i go out there we burn an
eye together and then calling another
mom and another mom
very quickly we became a bigger group
and i talk about that in the book logic
common sense
leverage people think leverage is a bad
thing no it's not that's getting to know
your neighbor
the minute we started leveraging
ourselves with the community
pg e ignored us with one and five
intimate when we came 50
200 500 600 they're like going uh
what's going on right here and that
creates an environment where
a whistleblower might feel more inclined
to
disclose what he or she knows i mean in
the movie the fisher-stevens character
like short of getting
you know his documents it would have
been a different story right so you need
to lead the ground swell but you also
need those people on the inside
who might be willing to share with you
something that you're not going to be
able to find otherwise
well you do and you're absolutely right
and roberta walker had already been to
the water board
and she had made a note on one of her
notes and i'm like what's this cr6
and she said oh there's chromium six so
she was already on it so when
i went into the water board that's when
i started seeing the documents
like the one i just shared with you so
oftentimes documents are there
uh on the intake somebody may or may not
know what they are
and files them and they're never
discovered again
or somebody clearly will make a
reference put this over here
don't bring it out again so there's a
whole lot of factors that happen
and there is a whistleblower they will
make a phone call you've got to go find
a document
and in a lot of these communities now
they'll come to me
and we'll go in with some documents i
can see
when the light bulb comes on and i'm
like yes okay
this community is ready to roll now
we're going to go over here
because they will catch on and they're
usually pissed and i
actually hope if people read the book
when they close it you get mad too
and realize that you too can do exactly
the women of tonganoxie kansas they ran
tyson out on a rail
the women in hannibal missouri they ran
for office in one my gosh in flint
michigan right now we have the youngest
gentleman on city council 19 years old
do not think for one minute
just because you don't have a phd or
you're a stay-at-home mom
or you're a cocktail waitress somewhere
or you're working as a you know a law
clerk that everyone thinks because you
have stilettos on and blonde hair and
big boobs you're stupid
we shouldn't be underestimating people
you can
do this find your cause whatever it may
be and it may not be water
you need the tips the strategy and the
tools
to fight learn them and game on
and you can do it and i'm telling you
the first step you take
and you you get just a little bit of
that win or you're like oh my gosh i
understand this
oh my gosh i got such and such a
neighbor to talk to me and you see it
it's contagious and the momentum builds
it's very empowering
that you can fix or change a law
or get involved or get noticed or get on
a superfund site or get information to a
doctor
and see what's happening change
in your own backyard i love it we do
that it's so exciting
we the people i think we the people have
forgotten to believe and we the people
also what you've done which i think is
really cool it's one thing for
you know you you always say like there's
a millionaire in brockovich is
yes there are to some extent but there's
only one of you and you're on the
receiving end of
you know i'm sure tens of thousands of
emails from moms and all kinds of people
saying this is what's going on
how do you scale that advocacy and you
created this website where
you're essentially crowdsourcing all of
these complaints and ideas and
putting them on a map and and you know
allowing people to kind of see
where these things are going on and it
creates these patterns and i think that
fuels like people's um sense of
empowerment in terms of what they can
get done
well i believe most all of us are really
visual
and we can't always see the big picture
and that's why i started community
health book which is under construction
right now right i went to it
i was in beta but it was up but now it's
like being retooled or something yeah
yes it was it's always been up but we've
first of all the person that i was
partners with in dc
has has moved on so i've pulled it back
but now we're
i envision the map as ways and
we don't have a place to report and
that's something that's important
um and how community health book began
so
i was just doing it myself again i'm
visual and i like to see things
but i also remember things so i would go
through my emails and there would be an
email from a woman in
illinois let's say and she was concerned
about a report on her water but what was
really concerning her
was a disease her child had and she was
concerned
that another child in her child's school
had the same disease
okay that's it you're in my head
and then a week later another email will
come in and i go
didn't i see this email last week so i'd
run a query
well unbeknownst to me not one mother
had contacted me but
five or six from the same town same
problem
oh all right i'm you know what i think
that's odd yeah i just think the side
so i started putting it on a map and one
day i looked over and there was like 350
dots i'm like what the hell
and was it did i read it initially it
kind of lined up where
with where the superfund sites were oh
absolutely and overlay so that whole
northeast quadrant lights up and it
matched identical the superfund site so
it started telling me all right
water environment superfund sites and
see we never come back and check on the
health and the welfare of communities
so what had happened was i was up
speaking to senator boxer and her
environmental working group
am i presented the map she was like
wait a minute what is that and
she's like why would we not know that
and i'm like
well i think people try to report but
for a lot of reasons i don't know
the information doesn't get stuck in
someone's mind it's in mine so i created
the map why
why wouldn't the epa create that for
them for
everybody well here is why and this is
this is r this is usually
mind-blowing for people so i was
testifying with the young boy by the
name of trevor
schaefer and trevor is a young boy that
had a brain tumor from boise idaho
and numerous of his friends did he was
really the only one to survive
he vowed that he would do something
about it in his life so he was up there
speaking
the reason we were there is there was a
reform to the toxic
substance control act happening which
hadn't been reformed
since frank lawton i mean it had gone a
long time
when that was reformed president obama
put
in that toxic the toxic substance and
control act
a law called trevor's law
that requires the agencies to build
a national disease registry
database because we don't have one
so florida kansas tennessee
every state has a cancer disease
registry
but they can't share that into a
national database because of
hipaa yeah so we can't find or see
people who've migrated away report back
is it a super fun site and we miss the
whole picture
so that's what really took community
health book off and i
visualize it as ways
if there's no national registry database
where is
a place that people can report to i am
down here in padre island texas which
just happened
and that platform just blew
how can i report that and if everybody
had a place to report you would visually
see what i do
it's like whoa hello this isn't just
hinckley
this is happening everywhere we
can't have a solution to a problem
if we don't see where the problem is and
this map
helps you see right how did
water clean access to clean water which
is a humanitarian thing
should be a fundamental right of every
human being become
a political football how did this thing
become
so politicized power
money privatization of water oh my god
my dad he used to sing these songs to me
all the time you know see this water
today trickling down the stream
enjoy it because tomorrow it might not
be seen he promised me my lifetime water
would become a commodity more valuable
than gold or oil
and i think there's a lot of movement
around them water rights buying water
rights companies like nestle
power money
and it's becoming more and more valuable
and
those that can control it and own it and
make the money off of it dominate and
those of us that rely on it as everyday
citizens that we've always thought as
this country began and it's what made us
so great was our infrastructure and our
water and our municipalities
they take the cheap route they abuse
funds
and bonding and they don't use it for
what they should
and it gets covered up and somebody
doesn't want to get fired and
somebody doesn't want to rat somebody
out and
money greed then socially
then it becomes a social stratification
thing lower income
communities very much short shrift on
this whole thing and then you end up
with flint
absolutely and you know hannibal was on
track to be flint
for a different reason we've got to take
a look at our municipalities and the
moms came in
yes and flint before why
why did flint become so fraught um
you know when it's one thing in hinckley
when we learned a big corporate utility
lies to you and you know can go to bed
at night not worrying if somebody died
from their poison because they buy their
own that it can't hurt you
um that was one lesson for us
flint was another because the agencies
all the way up to the governor knew i
think about this
ed somebody that i trusted if for years
he knew that what i was doing
was poisoning me and never said anything
this is a sock in the people's
gut and it it really takes a while for
you to go what the hell
so in flint they switched river water
which you can't do water's amazing
there is no two bodies of water
anywhere on the planet the same isn't
that amazing
it's like an individual fingerprint like
we are
you can't just add chemicals
take them out switch river waters
without a crisis and when they switched
river water
they were on detroit and they went to
flint it's much more corrosive water
different ph and when they ran it
through the system
it caused all the lead in the lead pipes
to precipitate out
yeah so i got an email from one of the
moms
a year before you even knew about flint
or anyone
i happen to be in australia and so
i can read between the lines it's uh i
don't know people will tell you i'm
psychic or weird that way i don't i
don't know about that
i don't know maybe you just have to
understand people sometimes what are you
saying to me and i'm not afraid to go
what are you saying to me
but i was like uh this is
odd uh no so i sent it to
the water expert that i work with robert
bocock and
he emailed me back and he goes i'm going
there tomorrow
so he went there tomorrow he's a water
master he knew what was getting ready to
happen
that municipality did everything they
weren't supposed to do
this was a perfect storm brewing and
all through the agencies it got covered
up because they all knew they all had
some level of culpability
absolutely and you know there's been
grand juries and the department of
health uh people going to jail
and i think that is one thing that maybe
we should start looking at when you
start mucking around like that
with your municipality and lead or a
chemical that's going to harm children
or a future generation
or kill somebody and you have knowledge
i don't know
does 600 million dollar lawsuit bother
them probably not
is pg e been phased by the billions
probably not but where i think they do
get phased
maybe you should sit in jail for 20
years
and bring it home to them because
somehow they become disconnected
and i don't know why somebody wouldn't
say anything but it was those moms and
dr monas see they started picking it out
together
and it's you know in high school when
you write
a thesis or paper and you're just
staring at the blank page
because like how do i even begin but
when you get the first sentence or
paragraph out you just kind of like
roll so when the first mom
reaches out to me and i'm like hmm i'm
out of the country
this got to get to bob right away who
has his own set of instincts that gets
to flint
that permission becomes support when the
support comes
it's easier for another mother to go oh
i'm so relieved you too and then another
you too
and then they start collecting
information dr mona is the doctor
so that's that's what happens is the
collective
is suddenly shook up and they get
together and these stories
hit the media they become national news
and let me tell you what there's
we've got 200 other led lights
oh my god you know we didn't learn
anything in hinckley
we haven't learned anything from flint
they did an
amazing job yes there's a settlement but
the problem still isn't solved it was
happening in hannibal it's happening in
new jersey
this is happening right now in a town
outside of albany the capital of new
york
we're getting ready to put up on twitter
every day i'm going to be tweeting
another city another town another water
crisis
i don't care i'll do it till i die that
has a lead contaminant
what are we missing here that's what
that's what's so hard to get and you're
somebody who's
sat across from these people you sat
across from ceos
board members uh you know government
officials from the federal level to the
municipal level
there is this idea i think that these
are mustache twirling evil people but
i'm sure in their own minds
they don't think of themselves as doing
anything wrong like what is going what
is going on in that culture
is it the is it sort of the
dissemination the
the distribution of responsibility
across many many people that allows
people to sleep at night or
why can't they shoulder that
responsibility and fix these problems so
that they don't
that's what's hard to grow to grasp as
just a
citizen of the public well um
we could look at hinckley that's a
company
for the sake of money that's getting
ready to freaking get caught
and we've been poisoning people and
they're gonna do everything they can to
hide that
flint but once you've seen these things
and you know these lawsuits are coming
and erin brockovich is out there
gunning for you can't they how can
why why can't they clean house and be a
little bit more forward thinking to
prevent these
flint type situations from happening i
think egos play a huge role in here
that you know it's a one-time thing i'm
not to get caught
catch me if you can a lot of
gaslighting goes on honestly it does i
know we're talking about these days but
taking
the minute someone pushes on me now in a
community to not look in the information
i immediately know you're
right and now i'm on it what are you
hiding from me
um but i think egos play a role
and you're right sometimes you know i
could
here's where we're at i could blame a
whole lot of people for everything
that's going on where the is that
going to get us
at some point i'm going to stop and go
you know i don't i don't know
listen the problem is here now how are
we going to fix this
pg e may be at that place now with a new
board and they're out a third of their
company
in the recent fires the government of
flint is clearly i think once we see
them
and they're in that hot seat puts them
in a different position
this is why i say what we the people can
do about it we the people have to make
it our business and our job
to hold their feet to the fire to hold
them accountable
to stay on a situation because
oftentimes they bank that we are simply
just
gonna go away and i think that tide is
clearly changing and
in all fairness sometimes city council
members
don't know what's going on if we don't
say
something and if you ever been to city
council meetings right no
this is one of the things you talk about
all the time like it's easy to show up
at these meetings there's nothing going
on
right yeah i'll never forget
in um carson
city california where the carousel track
is
shell oil and their tank farm had been
linking for years
and all that crude and benzene was
literally like beverly hillbillies
seeping up in their
back yard benzene
people with cancer kids sick with
leukemia i mean this was a lawsuit
and what we decided to do because nobody
would initiate clean up orders it's like
what the so i think people on the city
council are believing
the department of health and state
records that they're aware of this
they're going to do this they're going
to do that
so here's that shell game around so all
this disinformation is coming around
so we decided to go to the city council
and bob bocock was behind
this and it was so effective he got a
couple of city bus
you know school buses together and he
bust in
city members hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of them
so at the end of the city council
meeting they were all outside but the
city council didn't know it
they said you know we're ready to
adjourn and they can't adjourn until the
last person's been heard
so bob said there's some people here
that like to come in and talk about the
carousel track
they filled up the entire chamber and
what we did
was we gave them each a stuffed
animal guinea pig and each child
in each family member who had lost
someone from cancer wrote on a piece of
paper
what had happened to them and did a
safety pin
onto the guinea pig and set it in the
middle of the chambers
it was unbelievable you can't ignore
that and when they were done
there must have been a pile six feet
wide by four feet deep
of stuffed guinea pigs listening to
these stories and i will
tell you those city council members
weren't that good of actors and
actresses
they actually had no idea
and no clue what the hell was happening
to those people we need to show up
that's a very powerful example
yeah and it's not letting them off the
hook
meaning the city council but they truly
didn't know and how could they
they don't read our minds until we show
up and understand that they don't like
we just believe that they have our back
that they're fully abreast of all these
problems and they'll take care of it
and superman's not coming
that's our wake-up call you know it's my
wizard of oz theory
everybody that works with me i'll tell
you oh she's
not so she's all under her wizard of oz
thing
but i can't help myself i'm from kansas
and wizard of oz was one of my favorite
shows
but i'm not talking about the film i'm
talking about the book
wizard of oz and why elle frank baum
wrote that book which became the film
at the pre-height of the industrial
revolution
and he wrote the wizard of oz as a way
to teach his children
the power of individualism and thinking
for
one's self in a world that would
increasingly
begin to speak for you
way back when that intrigues me now the
book has a lot of political allegories
you can go look it up on google and so
dorothy is a representation of the girl
next door
all of us all of us girls in america
on a journey searching for you know what
our life
and our meaning and as you know the
story she goes
out and the tornado comes but in the
political allegory that's been
really studied by a lot of scholars and
l frank's bomb
meaning of telling a story through a
children's fairy tale
the twister represented disruption in dc
so when dorothy gets picked up in the
tornado
and lands on the munchkins they are the
mass citizens
who are pissed and they tell her follow
the yellow brick road
go down that yellow brick road and find
the wizard who will save us
who represents sitting president yeah so
off she goes on her journey and the
yellow brick road is a representation of
the gold
standard and in that time there was a
fight between the silver and the gold
so her slippers in the movie were really
supposed to be silver
so it's follow the yellow brick road the
path of money
so she meets the tin man and the tin man
is a representation of
the industry worker who's lost his heart
sound familiar wow the scarecrow is a
representation of the american farmer
who everyone thinks he has no brain
because the banks are buying up all of
his land
look at our farmers today and the
cowardly lion is a representation of l
frank baum's best friend william bryan's
jenning
always running as a populist for
president but never won because he had
no courage
so this is a representation of the
american people the girl next door
the politician the farmer and the
industry worker
so off they go on the yellow brick road
until they meet the wicked witch to
discover yeah who doesn't want them to
find out what's going on
so they got put to sleep in the poppy
fields
i wonder if that's where we've been um
and i wonder if we're waking up
and i'm wondering if we're discovering
exactly what they did
there is no wizard right the emperor has
no clothes all right finally
and we i didn't know that story look it
up on google it's a great political
allegory
but we the people we've forgotten we had
a heart and the brain
and the courage and i'm banking on us
we're gonna find our way back
[Music]
so the movie comes out
you become a household name like almost
overnight i mean have you ever thought
like what would have happened if
like if the movie had been called
something else like the chromium
syndrome or something like that
like it might have altered your life in
a very different way
i did not you were so right and i was
terrified so
it was finally the night of the rap
party and everyone for the law firm is
there and
you know this is still overwhelming for
me i don't know that i'll ever really
get it at some point i've let it go and
i don't know
well it's the craziest thing because not
only was a movie made
about your life where the title of the
movie is your name
it's made with like the finest talent in
hollywood like the best people across
the board
well two stories so when the whole thing
came out from that
get go carla schomburg at jersey films
you know
said egos get
can really mess people up and
she didn't know enough and know about me
but a lot of people in there like
you know someone's gonna make a movie
about you we get kind of like you know
listen this is pretty cool she'd always
say
we do this all the time and more often
than not they never get made right
cool so i went about my business ed and
i used to have conversations and he'd
say if this
if they really make this aaron who do
you think should play you i was like
i can't go there i don't know ed and i
spent endless hours together in a car we
drove up and down this state and all
over
endless hours i'm talking 12 14 hours a
day working
and um he'd say oh you know come on and
i'm like
um goldie hawn somebody fun i happen to
be a little zany in a little fun
most people don't know that about me and
you know goldie hawns fun fun
zany cute laughs you know
silly i can really be like that you have
to really know me to see that part of my
personality other than that i'm a little
bit
guarded um but ed goes um
no he says i was thinking maybe somebody
like roseanne barr and i'm like ha ha ed
and
[Laughter]
i go and he goes all kidding aside
i wouldn't care who gets the part as
long as it's not
julia roberts i go are you kidding me
first of all it's never going to be
julie roberts she never plays ed
so what was his beef with julia roberts
he didn't think her mouth was foul
enough
and her boobs weren't big enough and
he just didn't think as an actress that
she would be right for the part
so the day i got a phone call from
steven soderbergh and he said we've cast
the roll i mean my heart was beating i'm
like and he goes it's julie roberts oh
my gosh
yes i mean i could not wait to call ed
which i did
because i was at home and he got on and
i said so they've cast the role he goes
who is it and i just went knee and her
knee and her knee or he goes
no and then he stopped and goes
okay i tell me to cast
tom cruise to play and i'm like yeah
but when it happened and at the rap
and everything that was going on
everyone asked me what are they going to
call the film
so i'd only because i was the one that
spent a right the year with the writer
the writer
was in hinckley the writer was it the
meetings the writer was just suzanne
grant
she's amazing i've met her a long time
ago but
one of my favorite people she's playing
she's an impressive woman she is a
very impressive woman um
everyone said what are they going to
call the film well i knew the title was
erin brockovich
i just said i don't know the title of
zero breakfast they're like a stupid
name for a movie so
they said go out stephen soderbergh so i
went up and i asked him i said so what's
the name of the film
and he just had this deadpan look he's
like uh duh
aaron brockman i'm like
no yeah no um
that's when i got uncomfortable i got
even more uncomfortable when i saw it
for the first time and they actually had
my
maiden name in there and i'm like
[Music]
so um at that point people would know it
was me and it and i got nervous
how did that play out i mean i'm sure it
i'm sure it was
overwhelming it still wow yeah it's
it still is and i can't help myself um i
know people are always
will ask me specif what are you doing
what are you it's just what i do
and and there's things that come to me
and i'm i don't know if i'm a radar for
deception i don't know if i'm a radar
for reading between the lines
i don't know if that's because i'm a
dyslexic i've had to find a different
way to figure something out
not everything hits me but when it comes
to me i'm like
no way in hell and i really didn't know
after hinckley that
i would be hit from all different
directions not only in the united states
suddenly you become a target yeah i
don't know that that really
phases me anymore you know even out in
hinckley you
had you stole we used to always say
well if you get killed like you know
silk would but we'll definitely know who
did it yeah what
but i don't think that only happens
in the movies
right um well let's talk a little bit
about
water i mean we've kind of been dancing
around the the chromium-6 thing but
for people that are listening who are
maybe new to the idea that
uh their water might not be as clean as
as they believe it to be
what are the things that we should be
worried about what are these toxins
what are the worst ones what can we i
mean there's tce
there's phos there's pfao chromium-6
lead fracking chemicals like all of
these different things
you know we just turn on the tap and
drink the water
right you never think about it and
that's the thing that is scary because
you know these
chemicals have been in our system and
our aquifers and our environment
for a very long time and
many chemicals have latency periods
chrome 6 can be 20 years
i think that could be why we're seeing
an explosion of illness right now
because these latency periods are
running
and they're and it's it's the clashes
here i think science is catching up with
policy
latency periods are running so you ask a
great question
i will start with water 101
it's pretty easy and bob you know goes
everywhere with me robert beaucoc he's a
water master
engineer the expert there's nobody knows
water better than him
and i s i understand when he gets to
talking on the science because i see the
whole audience glaze over
and i myself am thinking i'm going to
have to throw water on my face
so we'll get in the car and i'm like bob
this whole long
sordid explanation about organic matter
i'm like
you know everybody in the room organic
matter it's a science term like i go
what the is that he goes uh dirt
and i'm like
why did you not say that you know it's
like my mom teaching me about
stick-to-itiveness all you had to do was
say stubborn oh i get that
all you had to do is say dirt oh i get
that i go oh
so it's dirt and fish vomit and fish poo
he goes yeah
so this is in our water bacteria
viruses all of it so when it comes into
the municipalities this is why we
chlorinate water
what most people don't know is that
organic matter
and chlorination create a very toxic
compound called trihalomethanes
right there at that point is where
everything begins
the safe drinking water act requires
that
you control your trihalomethanes because
they're toxic and if you don't
you have to put on the appropriate
filtration system
that costs money and a lot of it so
here's one of our first problems we
throw ammonia
into the system and we create
chloramines
chloramines cause a whole lot of issues
now we're adding another chemical to the
water we don't need more chemicals we
need less chemicals
ammonia renders chlorination less
effective
which is why we're seeing more
legionnaire outbreaks all over the
country
which is a bacteria absolutely it's
waterborne most people think legionnaire
is an airborne
it is not it is a waterborne
disease cdc is contaminated with it
right now because they didn't open their
buildings safely again
and when you turn the water on this wait
the cdc
has a legionnaires outbreak in their
facility yeah in their first building
we've been warning for months because of
covid and all the buildings are closed
down and the stagnant water
and you turn that system on if you don't
handle it right
you will have less effective
chlorination standing water legionnaire
and yes it was in the paper wall street
uh new york times post on it a month ago
we're seeing them everywhere
everywhere so ammonia causes
chlorination
to be less effective we're seeing more
legionnaire ammonia
also creates a thriving bacteria it's
candy
in the distribution system that can
cause
our infrastructure with lead to
precipitate lead iron and manganese to
fall out
hence we have more lead out breaks so
the pipes just leach
all of that into the water and it
further
deteriorates a distribution system so if
we would just stop the use of ammonia
we'd have
further we would stop further
deterioration of our
already in great need of repair
infrastructure
and we'd have less lead contamination
and we'd have less legionnaire
now talking about this one chemical in
the book we talk about a water operator
who is amazing
up in poukipski new york
he used the power of common sense
so he turned the ammonia feet on for the
first time
up there and what had happened was he
started to observe
everybody was calling him did was the
water
it's burning my skin my eyes sting uh i
got like this scalp psoriasis i have
like these burns and my hair is falling
out
ammonia feed goes off calls stop ammonia
feet comes on
calls start so he finally shut it down
and they had massive distribution and
they spent
millions and millions and millions and
millions of dollars in repairing and
replacing that distribution system
but the idea that he listened to what
the consumer was saying
what are you up to turned it off see he
started to notice that pattern
on illness off stopping so
ammonia is one issue called chloramines
that is a big problem in our
municipality
which leads us to our lead problems
chromium
6 is you know i learned after the film
uh chromium-6 don't problems didn't only
exist
here i was getting emails from 126
different countries and territories with
lead contamination
australia france greece south africa
india italy it's everywhere which kind
of made me think that's why
this chrome 6 there was such push not
for this film to happen because this is
a chemical
a lot of industry has used and you know
what it gets used in a lot
of stuff and then it it percolates
through the ground
into the into the water table is that
the idea and it's cheap
it's cheap adding ammonia to the system
is cheap
you want to cheat the system and you go
cheap
it's a problem every single time so we
have chrome 6 environmental working
group did a study
and that's in the book superman's not
coming where two-thirds of america's
municipality systems have chrome 6 in
their water
20 years later we're still having a
fight about it here in california
where we had set the first ever
maximum contaminant limit for chromium-6
in drinking water because guess what we
don't have one
anywhere in this country 20 years later
we still don't
this the safe drinking water act doesn't
define
safe right no just because which is like
insane
well that's just because it's within a
guideline doesn't in fact mean it's safe
because chrome
6 here california set the public health
the mcl at 10 parts per billion
the public health goal is 0.02
that's a huge difference yeah and the
law requires that you get as close to
the public health goal
as possible but the reason we don't is
feasibility studies
and the municipalities like we don't
have the money to do that
okay so fine let's just do nothing so
we've got
ammonia chloramines and the chromium-6
it's not an additive like chlorine or
ammonia to
help clean the water it's coming from
somewhere else and it's finding its way
industry and there are
very few locations they like to fall
back now on the fact that it is
naturally occurring and in some
parts of the world in some places some
of the mountains are producing that
but i will tell you 95 of chrome
6 contamination is from industry it's it
it's a rust inhibitor it's an
anti-corrosive they use it in
tanneries that's why you see huge
outbreaks in italy right so the runoff
from
those facilities i run off um it gets
sucked up into the system
you drink it you don't know it you don't
see chrome sticks
in water until it hits about 1 ppm
and by then you're pretty if
you've been drinking that for a while
you would have already known something
was wrong
um you'd have stomach problems and and
and you would it turns kind of a p
yellow and from there it goes green
and all the way up to about 24 ppm it
starts to turn purple
which the a soaps river
in greece is so contaminated a community
from there called onafita
reached out to me a third of their
children have cancer
long story short a third there's a town
in kalamazoo michigan
same scenario um mary clark another moms
on that one
all these are going to be in my book on
my podcast there is hope out there
again we the people right and when we
know we
act but we're on the apocalyptic part
right now keep going
we are but with this everything we're
talking about i think got us here
yeah it was about to boil over and i've
seen this
in communities for a while but in ona
feed to greece they are at the end
of the a soaps river and there's a huge
waterfall
and there their wells are right there
i'm not kidding you
wow look it up on google earth it
is so laced with chromium-6
the river and the waterfall runs
purple it's blue that's crazy so
chrome sticks um and the last one i'll
talk about so we're going to uh
the gte tce oh you don't want me to get
started on tce
i don't want to go too far afield here
but yeah but i will
tell you about pfos and here's what i
want to tell you because it is the
perfect chemical and the perfect example
to share with you how the system works
that's the one that's in scotchgard
right
pfos is the firefighting film so 3m
created
a group of chemicals 3 000 different
chemicals to create one family called
the perfluorinated group within that you
have
pfoa that you will know is teflon
and that was the big fight rob blot had
that resulted in the film dark waters
and his book exposed he went after
dupont for 20 years
because they knew and one of the other
chemicals
in that family with pfoa is pfas which
is
fire fighting foam that's what you would
know it at
scotchgard that's why you went to
australia last year
right yes because they have a big
problem too um
they're a little ahead of us in some
ways because some way they're
they're at least dealing with it
we are literally in our own
mess kit
we keep polluting the water that we grow
our food in
you've seen what's happened with
glyphosate we are eating
and drinking these chemicals we're in
deep trouble like in australia you can't
even eat the oysters anymore
you couldn't eat the cattle so now we
can't eat the oysters we can't eat the
fish we can't eat the cattle
what are we really okay this is a
problem
here in the united states some 20 some
years ago
3m did notify the epa that this is a
bad chemical our epa even sent documents
in the 90s to australia
better keep your eye on this one you
need to monitor this
now the big problem with this chemical
is
it's so persistent in the environment
you cannot you can almost not remove it
so here's what the epa does okay
we hear you we will create a guideline
for this chemical 400 parts per trillion
where the guideline came from i don't
know right
i don't think anyone knows and the irony
of of 3m
reporting this to epa instead of the
other way around like there is this
weird
it is inversion this conversation with
that right
so who's in whose bed so the epa creates
the guideline 400 parts per trillion
so they notify all municipalities you
can run this chemical
through your system up to 400 parts per
troy
boom life goes on
oh so epa then commissions a study
we have to understand commissioning a
study cost millions and millions of
dollars for one chemical
we've got some 40 000 chemicals hitting
the marketplace
so they commissioned a study to do the
science
what does this chemical do in the
environment to people okay
i just not laughing i'm laughing because
it's so ridiculous i can't even believe
i'm having the conversation but this
is what's happening and it's at this
point it's integrated into all these
products and being used
everywhere right in the water everywhere
well guess what happens
oh four years ago science catches up
with
policy in the foam rings yeah houston we
have a problem
this chemical uh probably not gonna get
out of the environment but it causes a
lot of disease in cancer
[Music]
what oh my god
so the epa is like what so okay well 400
parts per troy is probably two hours to
reduce it to 70.
so then they have to notify the
municipalities you got to go down to 70
parts per trillion what are they doing
what are you kidding me
we don't have the budget to do that how
are we utilized we could run up to 400
parts where now we're down to 70.
well then they have to notify the
consumer guess what the consumer does
they call me is this why we have
testicular cancer is this why our sons
in switzerland being treated for this is
this why i lost my daughter to thyroid
cancer
this is why my wife has kids community
after community after community after
community state after state
and i'm like what an ass
backwards way to do anything so here's
the thing
you get to put these chemicals into the
environment
first and we'll find out down the line
what the it does to us
with no requirement on the up front no
i'm the epa you will give me
a study of five to seven years to show
me
first what this does to the environment
and people
before i ever let you put it into the
marketplace that's insane
that's pfas it is the largest
contaminant in our national water supply
and that's where the history of this
country right now
so i just put out i think tomorrow on
twitter will be
um we just posted on facebook here in
california
in kern county there's a large aquifer
and we have aquifers they're banked you
know and it's where we bank
water and it's underground that we need
that the los angeles municipal
water district can't bank
that aquifer anymore because it's so
polluted with chrome
6 and pfos that creates a very big
problem
for a city like la in one of our
aquifers that you can't access
for water anymore so crazy and i know we
get like overwhelmed freaking fatigue
i'm with you but
i can i can pass on a lot of fights
we are water we are sustained
by water do not think that we might not
have water especially if we keep going
at this rate
and let's get serious about climate
change and we talk about climate change
in the book
and we talk about johannesburg south
africa where they
literally were going to have day zero
yeah
here's what they did what we're not
doing and where we can learn from
the people responded the people were
involved the people
rationed they did what they had to do
the agencies responded they became
prepared and they
diverted day zero
we've got to get and stop the argument i
don't care what side of the aisle you're
on
this is all of our issues we need to
work together
we need to be informed we need to be
prepared
and we can divert and there are
solutions to these issues the problem is
we won't get busy doing them
and that's where we have to go it's
crazy that in 2020
there isn't a technologically innovative
solution to this problem that doesn't
involve these toxic chemicals
like isn't there a way to produce clean
water for the consumer
without use of all of this i mean does
it eradicate the chemicals
we have to you know re-pipe everything
though we do
and we are very well aware that we have
that infrastructure issue
so we've managed to find trillions in
covid you can find trillions
to begin who's doing it right what
countries really have this dialed
you know france doesn't use many
chemicals europe does
well um they have the public water
everywhere in paris right you can all
all the fountains are are drinkable you
know they have they've protected their
sources they don't add more chemicals i
mean the game is to not add chemicals we
continue to add more
um because we have so much pollution
they're eradicating chemicals europe has
eradicated
chrome 6. we have it but i will tell you
and yes so they are ahead of the curve
on that because
they get water they get public health i
mean and i don't know why
i because i think our system is so
corrupt
and has so failed that everyone's busy
trying to hide it
and we've just slid further down the
road and it's to the point
where this isn't speculation this is
fact
and we've got
our leadership's just got to stop the
bickering and and i don't
care anymore none of it say it say it
uh we got a problem we got a lot of
chemicals this
is a solution we're going to have first
step no more ammonia
start eradicating these chemicals the
chemical lobbyists have a
huge handle on what goes on and so
europe does it pretty well australia
they definitely have some of our same
problems but they're
dealing with it we're not dealing with
this
it's such a vast understatement to say
that this is an important issue it's the
most important issue without clean water
there's there is there is nothing else
and that's why i say we the people make
it your business
tce that's a bad situation especially
out in camp lejeune but let me
before i go there trichlorethylene
widely used
definitely in our water sources aquifers
we're sucking it up
rivers creeks true tributaries dumping
by way of example
in minnesota tce has been widely used
and a community got involved because
their water and wells were contaminated
oh they became their erin brockovich and
they got the media involved
they stayed on this i want to tell you
about three four months ago
because of what they did bringing this
to light educating the community even
educating the media
all the way to the governor hmm they
have
banned the use of tce
boom there's one step that's not what
the chemical lobbyists want
that affects their bottom dollar that is
companies
in bed with our politician and these
things aren't dealt with
but minnesota did that's what they do in
europe in australia they're dealing with
it
we just need to take that step and and
say
houston we have a problem
i've always said we are inherently great
the problem is we're not solution driven
it's here i'm sorry tesla just
send us back out to space don't tell me
that
we can't find the money and you know we
can after the trillions and trillions of
dollars we've seen just spent
begin to address infrastructure
reduction of chemicals i bet you if we
would even do that
20 years into the future we might see
less disease
and a healthier population 100 so if
somebody's listening to this and this is
all new to them and they've been
drinking out of the tap forever
and it doesn't smell bad and you know it
doesn't it's it's not green and they
haven't seen frogs with two heads
how can they get a little bit more
educated about
the health quality of their water i mean
the water bill has like these they do
these studies every year right like you
can access that information you're
supposed to be getting a
water quality report every quarter right
no one reads that i don't know if i've
ever
read it so perfect example um you know
i've been on the book tour
and interviews talking to everybody i'm
here today so a reporter did a piece
about the book in phoenix and
so what's one of the first things i can
do i said get your water quality report
and read it you know you know it's like
an insurance company
policy we have one you don't read it
until your house is burnt down you're
like what the hell
give us take it taketh away what is this
i mean we
have to take accountability and
responsibility
for getting involved and finding out
ourself don't rely on someone else
but if you're reading it you have to
know what you're looking for if you
don't understand it email me
and we will tell you and it's pretty
easy so this reporter called me and
she's like
um i got my water quality report
and i have a bunch of chrome sticks in
my municipal water
we'll see here again we could get into
guidelines
and they're following a guideline by the
state at 50 parts per billion
but here in california we know it can't
be more than 10 parts per billion
the science says it should be 0.02 parts
per billion
and that because it's total chrome we
forget that a third of that is
hexavalent chrome so we have to speciate
it out
so the number means nothing and then if
she
not if she went to the environmental
working group and saw all the numbers
that you shouldn't have around the
country for chrome sticks in your
drinking water she exceeded that
and she said so you say in the book that
when by the time you get these reports
they're already three months
outdated i said yeah that's their lag
time she goes
so i've been drinking this chrome six
for three months i'm like
yeah and she didn't even know it
we can't just assume
i've learned this in 20 years or longer
in the field racking my brain to read
and understand and comprehend this
we can't assume that our department of
health
our state officials our city council
our federal government or any one of our
leaders
how's your right yeah my
instinct is
we don't just need an effective epa we
should create a new
regulatory body just for water just for
drinking water
you know the the with the barren of of
clean water
absolutely and why we don't and you know
listen we use chemicals and all these
issues in our water
we need what's called level five water
operators they they're basically
understand chemistry in this country
we're lucky if we have ten of them out
there and we have 80
000 municipalities so we have people who
don't know
chemistry and how to run the water at
the helm
and we talked about that in the
beginning do we have the appropriate
personnel on a front line for certain
issues
right and is that how things are falling
through the crack
and do we not pay for level five water
operators because they cost money
so if you suddenly got the call out of
the blue
uh from the president who said okay
you're up you're gonna run the epa
or we're creating this new regulatory
body just for water
what's the first thing that you do what
are the biggest
policy shifts or changes that could be
made
at the federal level i mean so much of
your work is is about grassroots but if
you are to look
at that you know from that that bird's
eye view
what do you start to set in motion
that's not happening right now
uh i in that getting information from
the ground
up to me you can't possibly come in
thinking you know everything that's
going on
scale reporting absolutely and even like
to the map we have no place where we can
see where you are
all at once so i would begin scale
reporting and
it boggles my mind
we are either inept or the system is
rigged
neither is going to work it's kind of
both and i think so
and we have to allow people to have part
of that process
and believe what they're reporting up to
you
now there's enough going on in the epa
so i was very uh
involved in um paid in west virginia and
an article just came out and
we really brought some attention to the
matter and
at some level finally because
of that pressure
the current administration heard and
they've now put them on a superfund list
so that means now they're going to get
some response otherwise they would have
been ignored so it if i'm head of
the epa i'm i'm putting in position
how that community gets to us to
to see we often ignore what they're
saying
and you can catch a water system quickly
if you'll just listen to what the people
are saying right
so that would be one of the very first
things that i would do and then maybe
the ability to dispatch like us like an
epa swat team to go interface with the
local
government local community create an epa
army
on the ground and you know we have water
keepers and river keepers and they're
the spotters that do just
that but when they report back you have
to act
and you have to be able to give them the
tools they need
to act is there any municipality
in the united states that's doing a good
job
poughkeepsie is right now
[Laughter]
you know um
oregon of late has been showing a lot of
issues
um but they draw from aquifers so
not everybody draws from aquifers um
depending on the time of the year most
of us get it from surface
treatment sometimes we mix and you know
we combine them
but that's how we get these issues in
minnesota where it's in the groundwater
and the groundwater fluctuates so
depending on the time of year
whether we pull from it blend blend it
with surface water
there's a whole mechanism that goes on
and so i rely my whole work
is it's an army out there of people
and they need to have a place to report
that's one of the first things that we
need to do
and information gets lost because you
got to get that website back
up it well it's up for them to report
but we're building behind it so
a lot of data is coming in right now and
it will be back there it doesn't mean
it's not going to exist i am getting
your information
yeah and i too have to be very careful
this isn't about getting
people's information and sharing their
health problems is about
numbers numbers are important so if
one's reporting and then
10 and then 50 and then 100 i now see
you and i knew
i know where i need to go and we don't
have that ability even at the
epa to see the big picture we have 50
000 mines west
of the us that are ready to breach just
like in the animas river
we need to see those with reporting
this idea that's up here you magically
know what's going on you're going to
report down to us
you can learn a whole lot of information
up there on the hill
if you let the people report to you
so you can see that the information
isolate the problem and begin
you can put ground troops to work right
what is that you can create a locally
good economy rebuilding your
infrastructure right i mean that's the
thing you got to create some kind of
economic incentive so that it
feels like it's in everyone's interest
to report
to move forward and to try to you know
and uh you know recreate
a healthier infrastructure absolutely
and if it's just looked like a huge cost
and a huge burden and people are going
to lose their jobs
absolutely not that is not what we want
we want it can create drugs when i look
at the map
blaming is going to do nothing it
initiates we are here
this is the problem what is the solution
there's
great technology there's a new
technology coming out
a mapping company and they're able to
start reading the water
uh like the weather so they're uh you
remember the show twister and they put
all the little
sensors in there yeah yeah so they're
dropping sensors
way up by canada and watching them as
they come all the way down to the gulf
these sensors pick up changes like in
the bin
and all of a sudden they see a big
benzene reading and they're like what is
that
well coming around the bin is shell oil
this isn't about shutting down shell
nobody wants to do that we all
appreciate lights air conditioning heat
traveling vacation our cars
airplanes going to australia all of it
but
it doesn't have to be all or nothing
when we see you we've identified a
problem
now what can the ground troops do to
clean up a mess
and create more jobs create better
technology
look at medically what's going on find
cures possibly oh
fathom that but we clearly could so the
map when we can see you
is a designation place for cleanup
for improvements for jobs for technology
putting it to use applying those
applications
looking at the health impacts looking at
medicines
or cures to make people better that's a
win-win right
early detection absolutely it's not
to shut down industry none of us are
asking that you know i talked the other
day
on the green new deal and we talk about
climate change
people it's hard on climate change you
can't really see it or touch it it's not
tangible
and i think that when you say green new
deal
the other side here is threat everything
that you and i are just talking about
we need to change our verbage how about
we rebuild on what we have
to make it more sustainable it becomes
less threatening
we have a problem and it's not tear
everything down
we have some technology here how to
rebuild
on that to make us more sustainable
and more safe and ways to have alarms on
systems that will tell you what's
happening
to put those sensors in the water to be
able to identify these
there's this idea that
there's no money to be made in the
solution
and nothing could be further from the
truth right and we need to begin to
implement that and we'll never get there
if we don't see the big picture and say
we have a problem now how are we going
to fix it and
start doing that and all of us taking
ownership of that
problem and that solution and shoulder
the responsibility of
participating in that kind of change
we're going to have to and i think it's
here
i i think i think we're off to a rough
start it's more than happy
i have to imagine you have some kind of
crazy water set up at your house
like do you have insane filters like
after everything that you know what's
your relationship to your own
intake of water a reverse osmosis we
talk about that and you have to know
your water first to know what kind of
filtration you need not
one filtration other there's some new
technology out there but reverse osmosis
has historically and currently been the
best way to remove
multiple types of chemicals at low
levels out of your water
so if you have pfos and you go
buy any certain filter to reduce
chlorination it's not going to get out
the beretta filter or whatever right
yeah and so if you have chrome six you
need more of like a coconut shell
filtration if you have um phos you need
more of a granular activated
carbon if you have a solvent you need
different resins
so that's why reverse osmosis is the
best and many people have that
in texas one of the congressmen is
looking at
very large rebates for families that put
reverse osmosis systems on their whole
house
it's one sure way as municipalities are
getting rebuilt and read whatever we
need to do
at that particular facility it provides
you a level of protection
at your tap and they will do large
rebates so that's very interesting there
are things that we can do at the
consumer level to get
those types of filtrations at the home
you can get reverse osmosis a sink mount
on your home and there are some
countertop reverse osmosis systems you
can use
but you have to know your water to
answer these questions and that's one
thing i think we need to understand
we're the ones that are going to have to
gather the information find your facts
and um find out for yourself and we
oftentimes don't do that we will
when we realize no one's got our ass but
we're going to have our own
superman's not coming i know it seems
daunting but i actually find it quite
exciting
because you know honestly um find out be
prepared
there's things that you can do where you
can get involved
and um water is
something that i just think we've taken
for granted and we can't anymore
so we the people
we have to take accountability and
ownership ourselves
100 i think that's a great place
to end it but i do have to ask you one
more thing sure i would be remiss and
not asking you what your thoughts are on
bottled water so many of us are drinking
bottled water and single-use plastics
what is your understanding of how these
plastics not just
impact the environment but are impacting
the water that we drink are there some
that are better than others should we
just avoid that
where's your head all of that you read
my mind because before you know you
sometimes you
get going way over here you have to pull
me back because i was gonna say
about bottled water um
i'm like anyone else i travel a lot and
there are times i need bottled water
i always look for bottled water in glass
is so much more easily recyclable water
is like a placebo
and you may need it on the run and
most bottled water is just reverse
osmosis
and the plastics is a huge problem
so i do need bottled water
i will search for glass um when you're
traveling you can't bring your own in
anymore
i use glass in my car my own mason jar
if i'm in another country and this is we
talk about that logic
leverage that logic is your common sense
and i've been in many countries where
i'm like you
i'm not drinking that i can assure you
you will not
die drinking beer as your water
or brushing your teeth in it and
definitely not showering
depending where you are um there may be
times you need bottled water
but bottled water is going to become
a big issue if we continue to have all
these aquifers that are contaminated and
we don't clean them up so
it's a as a luxury it's a little bit of
a placebo
uh it's a convenience and the plastics
are a huge
problem we just did a thing by the way
on
jeans and every time you wash your jeans
56 000 microfibers fall off
and that's falling out into the ocean
and creating other issues so
i think we have to really go back and
look at certain things and how
we in this modern society um
are contributing to a failing
environment and become more
conscientious
bottled water is going to be there it is
a necessity listen
right here if we have major earthquakes
like down after the hurricanes
um the last one in louisiana they're
looking at three to six weeks
so bottled water is going to be a
necessity to some degree
but i think how we store it um and the
plastics is an issue
yeah there's a difference between having
it available as a necessity versus
it being a daily convenience and we go
to plastics why
cheap cheaper to ship and i think you
say
in your place this is more expensive
like 97
of the water that you tested had like
micro plastic
absolutely yeah and so again
cheap everything we've talked about how
we end up in this way because somebody
hides something and somebody's going to
go cheap because somebody doesn't want
to do it on the upfront the right way
infrastructure safety people first
if you just did that we wouldn't have
half the problems that we're dealing
with now
and so the plastics became cheap
and i know they're working on different
plastics but that doesn't change the
fact that this went on for years and
years and years and years and people
polluting and all those plastics going
down the drain and
out into the sewer and right when stuff
gets in the sewer don't think that it
doesn't you know
just disappears it's gone right see so
there we go again
and another thing that's beautiful about
the map we're visual if we can see it
we're like oh
wow right we as a consumer
cannot take anything for granted anymore
and i do believe that we the people
have an absolute obligation to ourselves
to our family to our communities to make
it our job
to find out and be informed um there's
no reason why you shouldn't be
and to act and to find your own courage
and
not be afraid to step up and um get
involved
because superman is not coming no but
tag yeah
you're here we're it
powerful erin brockovich in the house
thank you so much
i do want to share with you it's great
to have this conversation because you
know when i go to parties and people ask
me about water and it turns into this
conversation
i'm telling you i know what they say
when i leave they're like oh my god
don't invite her again
are you kidding people are gonna freak
out it's uh
it's it's i know it's overwhelming
i feel it too but we can come back and
we can talk for two hours just about
pfas
but you know what i will share with this
on my program ram realize assess and
motivate
it's all about oneself realize who you
are assess who you are
and you know look oftentimes we look for
hero
and the only person standing in your own
way of being that hero is frankly you
and we all get that little negative
voice in our head that tells us do this
don't do that
you know realize that you can
have that strength and courage you can
find it assess don't assess your bank
account
just assess who you are what's your
character what's your loyalty what's
your respect what's your cause what's
your passion
and and what i wanted to say here is we
do
live in a crazy world i'm thinking my
head's going to spin off
i really do and it's just going faster
and faster and faster and faster and
what's happening for us
as people we're losing our mojo
and we've lost our motivation and we are
frankly exhausted
and what you need to do when you hit
that wall and you will
as you move into whatever your causes
are and it may not be water you got to
know how to fight and you got to have
the tools
one of the tools that you have to do is
self-renewal we're all on our computers
right
and when a bunch of data comes in or an
overload what do you get the blue dot
spins and spins that thing really
irritates me
that happens to us that's when you need
to disconnect
you must do it and
get back to a walk on the beach get back
to a hike
get outside and plant begonias go play a
round of goth
disconnect and reconnect to yourself
it's amazing when you do that you can
hear yourself
think you can feel yourself feel
you can take a moment to breathe
and get clarity and when you do that
self-renewal
you'll find yourself waking up the next
day
with some motivation and energy to
go at it again such an important point
you know we're in a moment right now
where we're just being inundated with
so many crises and it's so easy to just
get overloaded and to hear you
download everything you just did about
water it's like jesus
you know we're in there we got this
crazy
political cycle right now we have social
upheaval
we have covid we have all these things
and like now i gotta worry about this
too and
you're asking me to get involved with
this like i'm maxed out
kobod gave us a hard stop
take a breath um reconnect
and if that's sitting in your backyard
reading a book taking a nap
um i i think it's helping it's not
helping i think it's really put us in a
place that it was
it the computer crashed and i've said
that before
um and when it does it can be hard to
reboot
yeah but there's things that you can do
as you reboot
and one of the things you have to
remember is yourself and i need you to
forgive yourself
none of us are perfect you know what i
tell people every time when i give a
lecture i'm like
if you only knew how up i was you
probably wouldn't show up and they're
like that's why we're here
because we all have issues ease up
on yourself take a breath
be thankful for your child your health
your grandchild because there
is so much going on but but look to you
hear
you um forgive yourself for your
shortcomings we all have them
but you know what get back in the game
tomorrow don't quit
don't give up and allow yourself
to be flawed
um and let your vulnerability shine i've
actually learned that my disability and
my vulnerabilities actually became my
strength and my gifts
if i just stopped long enough to i don't
know say to myself
one day hey you know what you're okay
see we did it we went from apocalyptic
and we landed it hopeful
absolutely because change is opportunity
in disguise
got that off my website i did i
completely stole that from you
um thank you fantastic i don't own it
i love it i appreciate you keep doing
what you're doing
we need you in this world and i
appreciate all the work
honestly if i coughed i don't have covet
i just test it again
because i'm getting ready well i have a
tv show coming called rebel
oh you do well i i was going to mention
you've got a podcast that's about to
launch right has it launched already
third show's out today superman's not
coming and we're just getting ready to
do the pilot
it's a legal drama series inspired by
your friend here
um katie seagal is playing a rebel
get the hell out of here yeah i know
katie
well her husband's a very good friend of
mine well that's really cool
so that she's going to play
rebel and andy garcia was signed to play
the attorney
no way in that question so it's a
narrative
it is a legal driving legal drama yeah
written by christopher enough
abc now krista vernoff's uh susanna
grant
so she's been the head writer for grey's
anatomy and a lot of stuff
so um so that's moving forward on that
yeah
so like is it a series order already or
pilot
they're pretty sure it'll be certain
it's pilot
because i just had to sign all the
paperwork so i'm one of the executive
producers
amazing so pilot and we'll keep our
fingers crossed i don't you know you
know how hollywood no i know i know
everyone seems to be pretty confident
that's pretty cool so abc during covet
got rid of all their pilot um
series except two and we were once one
david e kelly was the other
wow so that's a good sign very cool but
i love
katie seagal she's the best it used to
be a running joke
my nickname was pig bundy
[Music]
so i used to run around and stellar
is crazy that is so crazy
it just keeps getting weirder right it
really does
but you know what i never go there it's
it's a calling it's a message
for every one of us i don't know um
the universe the energy the expansion is
just happening it's here and
unbelievable
all right well come back and talk to me
when the show when the show premieres
[Music]
you